situation au sénégal avec les députés
qui ont voté hier le projet de
modification du code électoral dans un
climat de vives tensions
l'opposition estime que cette réforme
empêchera l'organisation d'élections
transparentes
elle se dit prête à la confrontation
avec le président actuel macky sall ont
fait le point avec notre correspondante
sur place et la faam ouzou près de six
heures de débats une soixantaine de
modifications apportées au texte initial
et plusieurs points de blocage dont un
article qui prive les personnes pour été
condamné par la justice de leur droit
civique mais aussi politique
un article qui en l'occurrence
empêcherait des ténors de l'opposition
que ce soit khalifa sall l'ancien maire
de dakar ou encore karim wade le fils de
l'ancien président sénégalais de
participer aux prochaines échéances
électorales aux points de désaccord la
création d'une autorité indépendante
pour superviser les élections avec en
ligne de mire les élections locales et
législatives de 2022 mais aussi la
présidentielle de 2000 24 la tension
était palpable en ici dans l'hémicycle
alors que l'opposition accuse le
président macky sall de fermer la porte
au dialogue alors ces deux réformes
électorales a été voté à 96 voix contre
5 et nous avons recueilli les réactions
des députés à l'issue du vote le
président a appelé tous les deuils
politique et l'opposition qui changent
pas été au processus il ya le but de vie
jusqu'ici que ce soit le pds par le
biais de oumar sarr que ce soit le
pastis manson
que ce soit les qualifie sans trop
d'opposition pratiquement avaient
répondu à l'appel
maintenant au terme du processus et sont
dans une politique politicienne vous
comprenez comment ça se passe avec
l'opposition
mais le plus important c'est qu'on a des
points d'accord assez importants sur le
processus électoral sénégalais qui sont
à saluer et à encourager car on a peur
des élections la course
le niveau ils sont pas pressés de le
coach aura le café la capitale c'est pas
dans les marchés ou dans les places
publiques
mais c'est pas ça c'est pas jouer au
ballon et l'a pris comme c'est du
sérieux
depuis un bon moment déjà mais il y à
une élection comment dit on vote d'une
loi ici à l'assemblée sans que nous
présente macky sall le bourhis toute la
ville pourquoi at on besoin de mettre
les polices et dans toute la ville pour
voter une loi ça veut dire que c'est la
loi controversée des lois qui ne font
pas l'objet d'un procès et l'opposition
tirera toutes les conséquences
ce qui ici est que le mot d'ordre était
été et est nette et que nous sommes pour
la confrontation que vous l'entendez des
menaces à peine voilées de l'opposition
qui installe un climat délétère
ici à dakar entre les proches de macky
sall et les acteurs de la vie politique
sénégalaise alors l'opposition qui
d'ailleurs ne compte pas en rester là et
qui promet de riposter dans les
prochains jours le président macky sall
dispose donc de très peu de temps pour
apaiser ses opposants la loi portant sur
le code électoral doit être promulguée
d'ici le 23 juillet prochain pour être
dans les délais imposés par la cedeao